the Berlin wall built hastily in 1961 it
drove a line through the middle of
Berlin and became a physical division
between two countries mr. Gorbachev tear
down this wall on one side the nation of
East Germany with feminism and the
Soviet Union but on the other side it
was West Germany capitalism and a
booming economy after 30 years of
dividing two political worlds and leave
very little warning the wall is breached
and it's spelled Germany was now unified
but then what look at the map and
Germany is just one big country 83
million people biggest population inside
the European Union but scratch a little
deeper and there are some obvious
differences between the two halves east
and west so is this unified nation
really well unified the East is a more
rural region only one in five of the
German population lives there and none
of the big 30 companies listed on the
German Stock Exchange is based in the
former East Germany and there's a big
difference in population it's growing in
the West and declining in the East where
on average people live shorter lives
economic growth is slower in the East
than in the West
unemployment's higher wages are lower
and so is productivity but on the other
side after decades of communist control
the gender pay gap is much narrower and
there's a wider provision of childcare
you see where the border is deceit you
look for unemployment rates you see the
wall you look for income you look for
wealth you see the wall well plenty of
talented young East Germans took this
opportunity to leave their country and
head west was a classic example of a
brain drain where a nation or a region
loses its brightest people you travel
across East Germany you often hear
people saying that they've been
overlooked that the West does better and
all that feeds into one important factor
politics
this is Cottbus couple of hours outside
Berlin it was liberated by the Red Army
in 1945 and then part of East Germany
now here a growing number of people are
turning away from traditional political
parties and instead voting for a
relatively new party the AFD
the AFD supporters say voices the
concerns of normal voters its opponents
say it's extremist and racist support
for AFD rose sharply after the migration
crisis of 2015 when Germany threw open
her doors to refugees many of them from
Syria AF DS anti-immigration message one
at twenty of votes and now it's bolted
on a new idea that East Germans are
being treated like second-class citizens
Sturgess healthy yes
very um in my inch not Colombians in it
doesn't have much of a bedside know if
I'm not I think one kid we are going for
a Fanta critics say the IFA is simply
stoking up discontent in meetings as a
democratic society we need to talk about
in just situations yes
that is not justifying right-wing
actions and racist attitudes so we've
got tension between east and west
controversial politics major economic
differences but for those who say that
the government we really don't
understand any of this here's an
illiquid truth Chancellor Angela Merkel
actually grew up in East Germany she
surely understands the problem her
government now is struggling to find an
answer
you have probably ended East more people
who are against like our immigration
politics about our climate politics and
the people don't want changes they want
to stay like it is there are major
differences between east and west of the
continent and of this country it is
three decades since the wall since this
wall fell but maybe there's still an
invisible wall running the length of
Germany and that one may prove to be a
lot harder to demolish